and now on to a high school student in
California who's taking on her school
after being told she can't wear a mag a
hat to class
Maddie Muller says she was just trying
to show her pride in her country when
the school claims she had violated the
dress code the Clovis Unified School
District is telling the Ingram angle
that Muller could not wear the Hat
though because it wasn't a school hat or
a hat from a school club or activity our
dress code is actually silent on
political attire because we don't intend
to position ourselves to be making
subjective judgments about what is and
isn't political well now with me as
Maddie mom at school says there rules
about half the clear I'm not a I'm not a
big one and for hats and doors period
I'm not like I don't like hats indoors I
think if you're at a baseball game where
you're in the Sun hats and doors
I don't I don't care what had it is I'm
not really a big fan of it but they say
this has nothing to do with stifling
your political beliefs do you believe
that I would have to say that I
wholeheartedly disagree okay so what
what evidence do you have that the
school is actually discriminating
against your political beliefs currently
on campus as of today I checked today I
saw for Hillary Clinton t-shirts one
Obama shirt a Bernie Sanders hat and
about seven LGBTQ rainbow flag hats on
campus today
were they in classrooms yes okay that's
pretty good evidence okay so it looks
like if that's accurate I don't have any
reason not to believe you if that's
accurate then people can just kind of
wear what they want to wear and so I
mean I see kids coming out of school
they're wearing short shorts and
something like whoa my mother would have
yeah but they weren't lots of stuff
including hats and I've seen a lot of
political symbols on shirts it seems
like kids are encouraged to be kind of
mini activists which is it's not how I
grew up but that's how kids are but if
you're a conservative activist then
you're kind of a hater that's how the
dominant culture sees you why did you
want to kind of pick this fight which is
pretty brave
do at most probably public schools in
the country thank you I chose to pick
this particular battle because I ended
up at the beginning of the first
semester getting an internship with
Devin Nunez and David valide Oh during
their midterms and that's when I really
discovered my true passion for politics
and I realized that the school systems
seem to be trapped under the
government's thumb about what they're
supposed to you know teach what's
acceptable what's acceptable to force
down our throats in a sense and I
realized that it's not always the truth
so I chose that as a conservative raised
in a family that my family was made
through adoption so I was born into the
pro-life army and I just decided that I
felt like someone needed to take a stand
someone needed to stand up not just for
Clovis north not just for Clovis Unified
but wide for the conservative and
Christianity monitoring that's going on
on campuses okay so there's a federal
judge actually said or a judge if
federal judge said the following we'll
put it up on screen about megawhatts
well the Hat is something that could
invoke violence or invoke controversy
then for the safety of the students the
school is within its legal rights a
former federal district court judge
Oliver Wagner said that so your your hat
could provoke people to violence so I
imagine that gets thrown on the list of
reasons why this hat and they claim it's
not politically that is a problem yeah
actually that until the judge said it
had never been brought to my attention
Wow
are you gonna keep wearing the Hat yeah
I haven't been just because I know that
it's a big issue right now but I did
order a black one and I intend to try
and wear it on campus because black is
one of our school colors I'm going to
try it maybe today yeah maybe just it oh
the mag
can't say Maggie either I don't know
maybe have a silhouette of truth I don't
know what that today I went to see I'm
sorry today I went in to school and I
had I guarantee I'm the only student but
I had to get my support the blue
sweatshirt approved I have to get all of
my sweatshirts and shirts approved
through your office I put in office
before I could actually wear you look
pretty today
you look pretty edgy you look like get a
real trouble at school so all right well
it's very interesting well beef will be
following that's a nonconformist here on
the Ingraham angle we really appreciate
it